vous vous rendez vous allez vous calmez
vous faites le matin on s'est brouillée
chauffe pas tout seul respectez moi vous
essayé de m'arracher des mots et 12 h
pas de voix du nord chez votre pensée
non mais attendez bonjour c'est que vous
surfez n'ont donc tout service je vous
raconte me chauffe pas tout seul
respectivement qu'on voulait qu'il
arrête là non regardez vous aimeriez
alors à faire le buzz mélenchon chez
bourdin déclarent qu'ils voudraient vous
m'a demandé ce que je ressens ce que
j'aimerais que ça s'arrête bon
j'aimerais que ça s'arrête si les
banques européennes je mets le écouter
bourda ont fait une interview vous
essayé de m'arracher des mots et usages
pas de vengeance nord h et votre pensée
n'est ce pas oui tiens penser au fond de
vous même sur le jeu et moi même vous ne
saurez jamais parce que le fond moi même
à partir d'accords voilà alors vous ne
savez pas publique
donc tout ce qu'on peut tous
perquisitionné sauf ma liberté de
conscience et le fond de moi même
thueux macron il vous roule dans la
farine
parce que il prétend qui fait deux camps
en europe expliqué mois voir comment il
fait deux corps droit aux auditeurs à
moi il me retire alors d'accord regarder
la caméra bourda vous n'êtes pas dessus
d'eux mais personne n'a dit qu'on est au
dessus des lois
nous avons le droit non non non vous
vous rendez vous allez vous calmer parce
que je n'ai jamais dit d'accord oui vous
avez vous mêlez moore vous en voyez je
vais sur les murs ça mais vous rendez
compte des mots que j'ai prononcés
écoutons vous avez regardé quotidien non
je les regardais le quotidien d'avancé
les catcheurs décidé à le sketch oui oui
à l'essai mais vous saviez vous c'est
mon nom qui a commencé à mettre en scène
moi c'est vous bien sûr vous aussi
monsieur bédard je suis allé
perquisitionner chez pions parce que je
vais dire aux policiers le jeu ne
bousculerait pas policier oui d'accord
écoutez on verra ce que vous ferez dans
ce moment là parce que vous faites le
matin c'est précieux
la dernière fois qu'il ya une pression
comme ça c'était quand et où monsieur
bourdin vous avez préparé l'émission
annoncé ici non mais c'est moi toi et
moi alors alors un essai je vais pardon
de plaisir quand une autre question
d'art oui oui mais je vais vous répondre
à l'eau mais d'abord je commence par
dire ça quand est ce qu'il ya eu des
opérations de cette nature en même temps
chez dix personnes dans le nord de la
france dans ces pays il y en a eu chaud
et politique bien garni ou sinon c'est
clair chez serge dassault chez magna
maintenant mais il ya eu tant de fureur
c'était méchant c'est parce que oui et
bien parce que je redis futé est ce que
vous regrettez vous allez aimez ou vous
arrêtez pas je ne parle pas comme ça je
peux regretter soit vous êtes
journaliste vous vous faites je service
assuré van ce que vous regrettez mais
non je ne regrette rien veut dire quoi
ça le maire faisait nuit
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de voir
là et pourquoi je vais regretter un
comportement qui vous êtes monsieur
mouche d'ornement bleu ciel vous le
demande
heureusement que vous êtes là parce que
sinon je me demande où je pourrais
parler je suis déjà condamné par toute
la presse écrite qui a besoin de ces
balances pour continuer à faire du
papier
bon donc heureusement qu'il ya la presse
audiovisuelle pour qu'on puisse parler
j'ai le droit de me fâcher
je suis un méditerranéen jeu beaucoup
les bras et vous aussi et les yeux et le
reste et je me fâche